[Music]
let's say the thing I like my show I
like doing the show it's fun but my
passion is going on Twitter and
bothering Justin Bieber face now how do
you do it exactly I mean what are the
kinds of things you do - yeah just like
try going when they're chatting about it
you know I just kind of mess with them
my favorite one a few months ago I found
this picture of Bieber sitting in first
class on an airplane you found it online
I went I search for it on Google I think
we have the picture though there's the
picture okay that you found that picture
yeah yeah so then I tweeted that out I
said oMG look who's sitting next to me
on the plane and you know the whole
Twitter universe started you know
hounding it like this guy sitting next
to people on the plane I go guys
they're called Beliebers these idiots
and these these believers start hounding
me they start surrounding me and they're
like I go you won't believe this our
plane is grounded for the next hour he
never does this he says if you tweet me
questions all I answered them for you so
I was answering so they all believe they
all believe passionately that they
believed yea they believe oh they're
believers oh yeah
so like this like this girl you know
tweets me can you ask him if he likes
girls with glasses and I'm like I hate
to say it but he says he doesn't and
then some guys like Kenya Assamese come
to Australia I'm like you know don't
shoot the messenger but he says
Australia stinks and it sucks and he's
never going yeah I got along were you
doing this for basically cut to Monday
morning and my therapist just sobbing
and what I'd done with my life right it
was at the time it was it was still sad
at the time